hi this is a science hangout from
science mission I'm so that's your pie
we have today dr. indira my circle from
Washington University School of Medicine
with us she is an associate professor in
the department of obstetrics gynecology
pathology and immunology dr. my circle
was born in India where she lived for
the first eight years of her life before
moving to East Africa with our family
she lived that until she was 15 and then
moved to us for a school studies she did
her undergrad and masters in Sweden and
again moved back to us for a graduate
school so currently she is the associate
professor in Washington University
School of Medicine she is the recipient
of multiple awards including the
prestigious four-year pathway to
independence from NIH she holds
investigator award in reproductive
sciences at burroughs wellcome fun she
is also received national research
service evolved from National Cancer
Institute in addition she also won
postdoctoral fellowship award and
academic one network Leadership Award
let's introduce a doctor of my circle
welcome dr. my sofa thank you very much
to the sure it's very nice to be here
morning thanks for thanks for joining us
it's a really pleasure to have you here
nice actually does can you talk about
some of your background education etc
yeah as you mentioned I have lived in
many different countries and grown up in
different countries which has been
interesting because it's different to do
science and education and different
cultures but but I benefited a lot I've
learned
from the way things are gone or perhaps
not done and Tamia and the way science
happens in Sweden and and the pace at
which it goes and then to be here in the
United States set at a very competitive
institution it's a different ballgame
but but having survived two different
areas makes you stronger in some ways
that's good so you have a pretty good
research career and you have more ahead
of you absence kk Ken Kenny please let
us know about your some of the people
who helped you some of the role models
meant as you had in your careers yeah
definitely I mean my first first madre
de stand by my guru as his i would say
in india it was my father my father was
also an academic like me and when I was
growing up I wanted to be just like my
father and and it makes me very happy to
have followed his pod and one of the
reasons I wanted to do that was because
he not only was a great educator a great
scientist but he loved all aspects of
science he loved of course the research
the intellectual challenges so going
into a new area and discovering new
things my father when he was doing his
early studies he was on the first in
colonial India to go to Oxford
University in England and was one of the
earliest people studying the nascent
field of isotope geochemistry and
nuclear geology so he discovered some of
the early video dating of rocks and so
on so it's very exciting to know that
the second thing you like is the
collegiality of scientists because no
matter which country you go to go to a
lab or you speak with a scientist you
have a common language and and just and
yet friends everywhere in the world and
all of them we visited them they visited
us and so I grew up in the feeling that
all world all science was all the safe
you know was wonderful I felt safe and
comfortable as long as there was science
and scientists around and and we loved
educating and mentoring and he was he
was he was a great guru and his earliest
PhD students are now in leadership
positions around the world and we just
passed away a few months ago and and um
and by that time he had four generations
of trainees and mentees still stayed in
touch with him and would come visit him
and and and you know honored him and so
on and so his legacy lives on infinitely
beyond his specific life and that's
something that I admired and honk wanted
to emulate myself and so so I'm still
and I thought but today was my greatest
role model he's the one who encouraged
me and then beyond that it's been great
scientists from the earliest people that
I admired was James Watson the double
helix and Anne Francis Drake that had
made me want to study molecular biology
which is what I major in in college and
since then it's it's been since then
it's been more people in my field people
who have trained me and people from whom
I've learned one of the things that it
has been in common when I look back in
my life I've been doing research since I
was 15 I spend every single summer of my
life doing research and and every single
lab I've worked in has been a very large
lab and I like that I like different
model organisms are like taking a
systems biology approach to my science
and even when I set up my own lab and I
was small it was a small nap in the
beginning we still did took the same
approach which was a little challenging
without the resources but but that's
just the way I think and and it's worked
out really nicely in my career because
I've been able to be
many different areas and contribute to
many different areas and I'm always stay
excited about something or the other
because something's always working okay
so in addition to science I think you
are doing other things your family
you're spending time with the family can
you tell can you talk to us they started
something about your hobbies and what
else do you do other then oh yeah yeah I
do a lot of things I love LA I have a
marriage and have but my son my
husband's also in the same field a
different different area but the same
same kind of job I guess and we have a
sign who's 14 and I love gardening we
have a beautiful garden that I've built
essentially from scratch because the
Waterhouse was all ID and now now it's a
it's a pretty much all year round garden
that boots broke a buried in November
and I cook a lot and I'm hosting a
dinner swear I make I do multiple course
dinners with different not that fusion
thought of fusion cuisine and my people
from different places just like my
parents did have people not paying us
from all over the place and and I love
traveling so just perfect brush I just
because you travel anyway and I love
that and I have friends everywhere and
like to go visit we have other investor
but that was the main one stick okay and
doctors about your lab so how it is
organized lot people enough yeah so so i
was very fortunate when i first started
my lab here because well you know we
gotta start up what's called a starter
package when we set up our lab which
which essentially paid for part of our
celery and allows for the money to buy
equipment and and reagents and so on but
along with that as you mentioned i got
pants great independence award which is
a five year five year award that
was almost a million dollars which is
really great because that was on top of
my start out so I was able to start on a
very strong note and and hired a lot of
people early on which is unusual for a
starting lab because usually has not
been one tech and then you build from
there but I hired involved and really
invested in my all my money in people
and and did all of them so that's
allowed my lap I think to be very strong
and really bigger I mean work in
multiple areas much more quickly than if
I had done in traditional most part the
other and so so then it's it led to an
end plus even though I'm a basic
scientist I I've always been very
interested in translational research
which basically means that I like to do
things that can go from the lab to the
patient pretty quickly and and so I have
been very involved in speaking with the
clinicians and my department and each of
the areas in the department had
fellowships which are essentially their
postdoctoral fellows so these are people
who have finished residency and are now
in their fellowship and usually they do
research in the fellowship so we have
set it up so that people who are either
studying or either doing high-risk
pregnancy or uragan ecology fellows come
to my lab and then medical students come
to my lab as well so we have a very nice
mix of senior scientists a senior
postdoctoral fellows but also a number
of issues students md PhD students and
political fellows and then a series of
undergraduates and because I as i
mentioned i started studying working in
a lab since i was 15 and I was always
very grateful to old people who gave me
an opportunity because I didn't know
anything but they gave me an opportunity
anyway and so I swore that if I ever
ever had my own lab that I would nurture
young scientists and so I've
high school students and undergrads and
now the trained about 14 of them and and
I'm extremely proud these are my
children too okay and about those about
your very success projects and the plot
what we are apparently today presenting
sure and so so I'm going to present one
of an area that's extremely hot right
now and much in the news which is the
Zika virus epidemic especially in
pregnancy and but the reason we came to
that which has only been is less than a
year since we've been doing it and but I
came to it from this first started for
my PhD research in studying host microbe
interactions in the intestinal
epithelium and then tested and so that
was my first foray into looking at
interactions between commensal microbes
in the gut I got microbiome with the
Gajapathi Liam and the gut mucosal
immune system so i was studying what
quiet I put my advisories to call the
trial on between the immune system the
microbes and the mokosa lighting and I
got very excited about that I like
looking at things holistically and
looking at all the interactions as
opposed to a deep signaling pathway and
then when i did my postdoc i moved into
another mokosa i started studying the
urinary tract where there is most like
this only if there's not like a rich
microbiome associated with it but Leon I
tracked is susceptible to a very common
infections earlier electronic market or
UTIs which are particularly common in
with so so I started studying that area
and made two major discoveries during my
postdoc one discovery was that that
these coli that caused infections
established reservoirs inside the
bladder mucosa and and and when even
though that people see
recovered and there's no active
infection clinically you might have been
two divides politics and you don't have
any bacteria in your urine there's still
a very high risk of recurrence and
recurrent utis are particularly bad
because often they become a factory to
antibiotics so so then you get more and
more and more severe infections and so
so when we discover it and I discovered
that there were these reservoirs that
was a big breakthrough that the matter
itself could be seeding new infections
and so and and those reservoirs are
resisted are are not visible to
antibiotic therapy because antibiotics
are only in the in the bloodstream and
we close up not they don't go
intercellular so identifying that was
was huge and so when I set up my own lab
now I've continued to that has led to a
project trying to identify first how do
the bacteria get to this reservoir what
is this reservoir what is this location
and how did the bacteria survive
long-term so that's been one area and in
that process have discovered that a
recycling system call autophagy is
essential autophagy is a recycling
mechanism that is present in every cell
and the main purpose is to recycle dying
mitochondria and a misfolded proteins
anything that needs to be degraded so
that new amino acids are produced and
then they go back into the cycling it's
just a recycle cleanup system and it's
also important for recycling or killing
a microbes which are foreign objects
that are coming into the south but we
discovered that e coli Europe lt-gen
akiko live which is the bacteria that
cause urinary tract infections are able
to subvert this mechanism and use it so
they actually go into a structure hole
in autophagosome which is a protective
double membrane structure and persist
there for long periods of time and then
we ask the question how is it that the
bacteria living in this little ocular
space because if not nutrient-rich
and and so how are they able to do that
you pack bacteria are not obligate
anaerobes they typically don't have an
intracellular life cycles how are they
surviving so that met us into a new area
which we're very interested in which is
iron biology so turns out of course you
know iron is an essential element it's
essential for all apart normal functions
and everything and both are coastal
cells and immune cells need I for normal
functioning but so which is why these
cells store iron but not know what
stores free iron which is which is what
is needed for function so iron is stored
it in complex for that with a substrate
called keratin and whenever the host
cell needs iron disparaging bound iron
complex is is processed through a tapa g
and and cleaved so that freon is
released and then can be so turns out
that this process of phrenology and goes
into all the ferritin and iron goes into
the autophagosome and then and then it's
clean and free iron is released so the
bacteria are constantly getting food
coming to them which is made basically
the reason they can persist so now we've
been able to starve the bacteria but now
we have an avenue to get at the bacteria
without antibiotics is that we can we
can block their technology we can we can
chelate iron or we can inhibit etapa gee
you've done this in cells we've done
this in animals and our next step is not
translated into comment where if you can
modulate dietary iron so that the person
is not or the animal is not anemic but
you he laid enough iron so that the
bacteria loses the battle and they get
starved out and then they don't come
back out again so this would be a non
antibiotic method of getting at those
bacteria so that's one area and then and
then the second area which then comes
back as a stone the bladder is that when
they coli bacteria first come into them
Costa
they invade into the bladder cells and
multiply and lead to a lot of death of
these lot of death and damage and a lot
of the cells which are important for
barrier function in the bladder because
you see the bladder stores urine which
is a waste product so you don't want any
waste products in the urine crossing
from the urinary space and back into
your bloodstream so to do that the
mocosa lining is very important but when
you get an infection a lot of the
umbilicus lost because the cells are
dead because they've been infected and
so in order to not compromise our our
host stuff are violet our host
physiology there is a very extremely
rapid stem cell for half program that
gets activated to replenish these
barrier cells so it's one of the most
remarkable things that bladder normally
would only turn over once in six months
but we have an injury I can this
infection it starts turning over within
6 to 24 hours it's one of the most
rapidly orchestrated stem cell
regenerative response evernote and all
the real consistent so so i was very
excited about that and i started
identifying the mechanisms behind this
stem cell activation and and ended up
identifying a series of pathways that
were really important with his purpose
and then going back to my original
interest of looking at the coast sound
bacteria and the immune cells turns out
that certain immune cells are truly
important in modulating the commute not
only the immune response to bacterial
but equally important orchestrating the
regenerative response after the
infection so you have to kind of
modulate it very carefully because you
need the immune cells produce
pro-inflammatory cytokines to get at the
bacteria but then you want them to
switch and and and and it starts to
creating Pro regenerative
molecules to help with clear generations
so we started looking at all the
mechanisms involved in that and and that
led us into looking at aging because in
aging women in postmenopausal women so
basically women over 50 or so who have
low levels of estrogen this entire
process is significantly delayed this
regenerative process and the immune
response and because of that so the
barrier doesn't get restored stowe do so
postmenopausal women are at incredibly
high risk of getting multiple and
infections and and so we started
studying that and now we've been able to
because you understand the mechanism in
your mechanism regenerative mechanism
mechanism of bacterial persistence and
recurrence were able to put all those
together integrated to study the
pathogenesis of beauty is in older women
well in aged mice but since we have our
your gynecology colleagues and fellows
in the lab we have samples and from from
women who come to our clinic and we have
large clinical study which very getting
patients and now we tried to integrate
with a part in new research as well as a
dietary iron research both in our mice
and in our way at concurrently so we're
really excited about that so that's the
bladder and and then and then um when I
started my new job here in this
department as a new assistant professor
in 2008 there was a lot of interest in
my bringing things that I had work
developed in the air night track to see
you it was also happening in infections
in the placenta during pregnancy so
turns out turns out it's been well known
ahead of time that that you know many
women go into labor early and deliver
prematurely and it's it's a pretty big
burden on society to have a premature
baby because up and it's more prone to
infections it's
it's lungs are not as well developed and
many other things they can be at risk
for a number of conditions later on and
and infections have been most strongly
linked with Peter Berg and so people
also any woman who's at risk his often
put on prophylactic antibiotics
forgiving antibiotics to visit to to
reduce the risk of infection but when
they did a large they did a large
randomized control trial with a gay
prophylactic entrepot antibiotics to
some pregnant women and not to others
they found that the women who were given
antibiotics in fact had a larger risk of
delivering prematurely than the women
were not which was which completely
through a loop you know through loop
down because now well like well what do
we do now you know and and so when I
came in the house wanted you to
investigate we start to investigate
whether there were reservoirs of
bacteria just like we found an effective
ladder that may be causing these
infections which would also be not
amenable to antibiotic tree and so we
started looking at looking for these
microbes and we found them um but we
found them in pretty much every every
percenter so so then at first we thought
we were all completely we were doing
something wrong and it took us a couple
of years to sort of like figure out that
no it was not wrong turns out that the
placenta has its own microbiome and it's
always been considered sterile and so
whenever people saw any microbes they
were treated with antibiotics which it
wasn't necessarily the best thing so
turns out the placenta has a microbiome
so then we published out the first paper
that showed have the one over microbiota
that might be living normally in the
center and and then that started as
thinking
investigating the simple microbiome and
then that also started us thinking so if
there's some bacteria that are not that
are normal and not infectious that means
that they must be mechanisms in place in
the placenta to differentiate between
the two and also the Poisson jaw is
remarkably resistant to most infections
because think of all the things that we
might be faced with but most babies are
stillborn normally without being
infected so we started looking at not so
much the infections with acenta but the
microbiome and normal defenses what are
the more more host defenses in place and
that brought us again to a top 50 and so
there's an area in the center where
fetal cells are bathed in the front of
life this is where all the nutrient
exchange happens and and so that area
has great high levels of ecology and
because anything that's not good that
comes in is recycled immediately so
there's just high basal level of
autophagy activity and turns out that if
you modify this autophagic activity
level you now suddenly increase the risk
of getting an infection so so that so
we're now is starting at Apogee in the
center which has been also extremely
exciting and in the process of all this
we you know the Zika epidemic came on
and one of the biggest aspects of
infection the reason it came in to miss
so much was because babies were being
born within small heads this mission
called my except where it's like much
smaller than normal um and so suggesting
that something was happening in
pregnancy that was I mean so we
immediately started investigating was
most going on and we were the first to
show we had a paper and sell in May of
last year showing that
Zika virus even if mom is infected a
subcutaneously like to the mosquito
which carries the virus the virus goes
and crosses with the center and in fact
overcomes this central barrier and is
able to cross over into the fetal blood
vessels and Vito lat strain from where
it goes into fetal brain and killed a
lot of cortical neuron or progenitors
which is what in large part leads to a
small grain structure forming the cortex
simply doesn't corn and so so we
identified that and there was a transfer
central route and then most recently we
had a paper in nature last month which
was very exciting which showed the first
therapeutic intervention which was a
monoclonal antibody against a viral
envelope protein that actually could
block the virus from crossing the
placenta so it stopped it on the mom's
side did not let it cross do not let the
virus across to baby side and the
fetuses were born normal and
undifferentiated from indistinguishable
from wild-type humps so so that's been
huge and and so now we're continuing to
look at potential barriers and how does
Zika basically break the barrier and
using the canal kind of us a method to
understand how the barrier can be broken
yeah so as you can see I work in a lot
of different areas but they're linked by
the fact that we're just chasing the
question and if the question that is to
the new methodology then we adopted
methodology and don't we collaborate
with someone who has that methodology so
I just always believe in following the
scientific question pick take over the
signs lead and you have the data to
share yesterday may I happen to share
the data on any questions then I can
answer I think after the data
presentation I'll ask a few questions ok
perfect all right so this is just a few
slides so I'm kind of lightning um can
you see the slides not yet no have you
shared it on the oh that's right I have
to do that won't able to see that yeah
okay so um can you see my cursor your
perfect and i just put together a few
slides this is all recently published
data and i just wanted to give
highlights so if you have questions i
can go into more detail later um okay so
a lot of this work yeah of course it's
always the people who do the work and
this work has been done tirelessly by
most brilliant postdoc after Vince al
he's been in my lab now five years and
he is ready to take off on his own soon
is interviewing her back into positions
so by the end of the year you should
have his own lab and he's just been
extraordinary working literally
literally working there night to in this
in this very fast-moving area so um can
you see the whole slide yeah okay
perfect so as I mentioned Zika virus is
typically transmitted via mosquito it
shares a lot of homology with the West
Nile virus dengue virus yellow fever
virus a lot of these viruses that that
that are ticked more or mosquito-borne
and it's it's a single-stranded RNA
virus basically does it doesn't have
protein so here's the RNA structure and
these are the the proteins this is the
non-structural proteins that are
important for the envelope and one of
our colleagues solve the crystal
structure last year and so not much has
been known about this far
it was discovered in 1947 in the Zika
forest in Uganda which is what gave it
its name Zika and they knew that it
could infect impact monkeys and and that
was all no it's not there was a small
paper from my glory 7 describing that
and then live in sporadic episodes here
and there in the world and which which
led to that understanding that that
mostly if you get infected you have
symptoms like fever that can be a skin
rash joint a headache and conjunctivitis
but typically symptoms go away between
three to five days there was an epidemic
small epidemic in in French Polynesia in
2007 which brought see come to attention
for the earlier times because people
infected with this virus had BN bar in
Paris syndrome which basically is like
temporary paralysis in adults and and so
they had many cases of bed but the
biggest interest started coming in 2015
make 2015 when someone made there was a
lot of talk and use coming out of Brazil
especially the north and northern part
of Brazil an Amazon forest area in the
summer that they were babies being born
with small heads and thousands of them
it was like just like that suddenly
there were thousands of babies the
hospitals were getting flooded with them
and so then they immediately started
investigating and realized that that
because they were all infected with this
one parts because identified to even
Zika virus the other troubling things
that people saw was that not only was
the head small but there was what's
called intrauterine growth retardation
which is basically a small baby even
even if it didn't have a small head the
whole body was small was just smaller in
size and and and and there was another
thing
called placental insufficiency because
the center that basically nurtures and
feeds the baby when it's an in literal
was also small so everything was not the
center was smaller that the baby is
smaller and so on and so now we know in
humans also that there's a river or
transmission from mom to baby and now we
also know that there's sexual
transmission so it can go from male to
female and also from female to male but
male to female of course is risky
because the risk part for pregnancy
because because the virus could survive
in the vaginal mucosa and if it's in the
vagina it can go up and in fact in fact
the pregnancy and effectively and now we
also know that males can get infection
of the testes and Emma queres can
persist in the testes in cm for a very
long period of time as well so it's a
pretty bad bad bad virus hey was so so
given given that these things that were
coming out about about the small small
babies and and with the small brains we
wanted to immediately start working on
generating animal models to study the
pathogenesis and figure out how this
infection was happening and we focused
on mother baby transmission and and
trying to prevent that in an animal
model so to do this we collaborated with
my client who's a famous and very well
established its expert flavivirus
exports so he's worked on West Nile
bengi and all these TVs she's a very
very well-known viral immunologist here
at Washington University and has had an
interest in new viral epidemics emerging
viruses a long time so he heard about
Zika at a meeting in 2015 on emerging
viruses and and so he decided to start
it all big animal models to be able to
look for this impact study this emerged
the problem with this infection is that
is that if you have an infection
and so the virus actually doesn't
necessarily cause infection in a
wild-type animals though he ran through
hundreds of mouse models so you identify
mice that were could get infected and he
identified mice that were deficient in
something called interferon receptor
alpha interferon alpha beta sigma which
is important because that is a mechanism
that virus uses to it has to inhibit
into fair on signaling in order to do
its infection and that's why I'm a lot
of antivirals are interferon activators
because that's that's what gets rid of
most of these artists so anyway so we
and so then where we got in with him was
to study pregnancy so we basically took
interferon deficient mom's the female
mice and and we made it them with
wild-type mice so that the center and
fetuses would be heterozygous okay so we
took him we took those crosses and
infected them in the moms subcutaneously
dominica mosquito bites with the Zika
virus at different days during pregnancy
and then we analyze what happened
comfortis and basically you can see here
this is a wild-type infected I'm sorry
this is a lot of type of animal infected
with the virus these are all the
different fetuses with their own
placenta it's all looking normal whereas
the ones that if naar het moms and their
placentas are black and fetuses are
resort and even the ones that you can
see the beauteous is a much smaller
about and the placenta is smaller and a
lot of these pups didn't get more and
then this is in the if na na advice that
she also developed another model where
we could take wild-type mice and block
them with an antibody against interfere
receptor signal so this you could use in
wild-type mice and and still be able to
block it and when we did
is it was a slightly milder phenotype so
we could look at the pop step becoming
they were getting worn and you can see
that if you had the infected in our head
mouse this is the level of resort so
most of the pups died only if you were
born and those that were born were very
small but if you treated with the
anti-fur antibody you had some so the
pups that were born but this don't have
the small bodies and center work or
smaller which is what is shown on this
slide so we examine the placenta from
these animals and this is this is the
the myometrium this is the muscular
lining of the uterus and this is part of
the mountains uterus and then and then
and in this area is called the decidua
which is the former uterus that becomes
part of a pond section of the center
here's the fetal Center and then you
have them the report going into the ok
so the baby would be on this side this
is a wild-type and this is in the
knockout just mock-infected in the
former and this is in the if not nugent
mouse you can see the placenta is much
thinner and smaller and when you look
histologically here is a normal
histological section some blood cells
some triple blood cells and then in the
shower head infected you see there's a
lot of loss of cellularity and anees
collapsed blood vessels then when we
look to deeper at the tropopause so just
just orient you for those of you though
by the presenter very much here again is
the my matron which is a muscle layer
here's the decidua which was usually
formerly the moms uterus that becomes
the decidua and offers the outer layer
of the center then this is anna mouse
then there's the junctional zone and the
labyrinth of the junctional zone which
has sounds called a triple us which
perform a lot of the function of the
center and then you have the labyrinths
all of this area here is my mother's
blood and these are feed all this is
Rattus fetal blood here and
of the fetal Kepler is fetal endothelial
cells and in between our additional
chief applause which form the berry ok
so these drug laws are shown here and
the nuclei are 12 plus nuclei epicentral
cells and all the red or viruses so the
virus can go into the trophoblast it
multiplies and essentially damages the
chopper was so so the virus comes name
from spinal artery goes into these
trophoblast and basically destroys its
way through and then goes into the fetal
endothelial cells I'll go through this
very quickly but here is a virus here
it's replicating and getting assembled
in the rough endoplasmic reticulum of
the fetal capillary so you can see that
the bar is sexually like making more of
itself in the fetal capillary and here
is a stain in red for the PL capillaries
so here are the nuclei and your
capillaries are normal pepper is an
uninfected animal uninfected percenter
and here is an infective acenta you see
all the calories are collapsed because
they've been infected and damaged by
Zika infection because once it goes from
here all the way across the tropopause
layers which fills the top of us those
are the fetal and filial cells kills
them lots of them and then it's in fetal
blood and from there it can go straight
into the fetal brain and this is the
review that we published in the new
england journal of medicine last summer
which basically summarizes our findings
which here's the virus it goes into
these maternal auguries from the moms
blood goes in and it crosses the the
junction zone and it goes into what's
called the labyrinth zone here and this
is where it crosses from the moms blood
across across the top of us into the
fetal capillary and from there you can
go into the brain so this was pretty
clear evidence that the virus was taking
advanced of central routes do the bait
and so then of course you know so
knowing that you want to be able to stop
it and for this one of the major efforts
we've been taking is to try to develop
new vaccines or antivirals and for this
we had a collaboration with jim crow who
is chief of the human vaccine center
amendable to music and he basically gets
blood samples from the cdc from anybody
who's been infected with Zika and he
isolates another any human monoclonal
antibodies from that infected blood and
then screens the antibodies against
binding to an envelope protein of the
virus and then identified one of 101
monoclonal that had strong activity
against the protein and then we put this
virus into our mouse model of radiance
and basically are the results were
really fantastic so again here's the sum
total structure here are animals that
were treated before infection annals
after infection with the monoclonal H
117 ends body here's an uninfected
animal you can see that the monoclonal
basically essentially got rid of the
virus in the center and here is our
minds that were treated with the
monoclonal against chikungunya which
doesn't do anything and here is a lot as
a Zika infected animals you can see
there's there's a level of infection and
here's relative uninfected so overall
the placental area central thickness was
restored so this is smaller percentage
this is normal the center and the
central area is restored and when we
looked histologically cellularity of the
placenta was was essentially we could
restored so we didn't have any real any
damage stroke was damaged we looked at
where the viruses were and here again
the center's this is the chikungunya our
control this is Zika infected animals
just treated only with the PBS
well and here's the H 117 here's the
placenta and when you look at where the
viruses are you see them all to the
placenta here and here but here you see
that there's no more viruses so
basically viruses just do not represent
and and and that resulted in a much
lower percent alone overall and then
finally looking at the fetus and then
the ileal cells here CH 117 treated
animals and their vessels book as normal
as those in uninfected elements whereas
the Zika infected ones still had a lot
of damage of people and the helical
cells and then finally when we looked at
the fetal physicists themselves we found
that most of the fetuses were intact and
the fetus fetus size was pretty much the
same as an uninfected animal and there
was very limited fetal load a lot of
virus campinas so basically just didn't
go into the lake so now answer that was
tremendously exciting and that antiviral
are monoclonal is being tested in
non-human primates and students should
be going into human clinical trials so
we're extremely excited to have
participated in that um so now we're
looking at a variety of questions most
predominantly how is what's the
mechanism now we know it crosses at the
center and so how does it do it so now
we're going much more detailed in cell
biology um we're also looking at doesn't
matter when you get in edit during
pregnancy it appears that if you get
infected earlier the severity of
infection is greater and if you get
infected later in pregnancies we're
investigating that and then and then of
course we want to translate a lot of fun
or findings into our human studies so
that's just a few of the highlights of
our work and happy to answer any
questions
yeah thank you so much can you and share
it yes yeah it's a very neat work I mean
like in such a short time yes a short
time not even a year for all that yeah
you're able to get some very nice
publications and some good work and can
you talk a little bit more on those
antibodies like how are they in the
clinical trial at the present or like
you're planning on that like how does it
go yeah so that that is not in my hands
because that's being done by our vaccine
colleagues and Vanderbilt but they are
going we are in the early stages of
going into final answer and regarding
the molecular mechanisms like are you
looking at the biochemistry what is the
pathway what receptor does it mine and
all those things yeah so my colleague
dr. diamond is investigating things from
the viral perspective and the
neurological perspective via we are
using our understanding of the central
trophoblast ology and and and trying to
understand my how is it that virus
reaches the central barrier so that's
the area of interest right now and we
are we were we're putting together a new
paper on on on our understanding so
maybe next time I talk I can show that
with okay that's good and one question
is regarding like guys like one of the
major thing is that microcephaly yes so
like and recently i think i've seen some
other like it affects other organs also
yes yes so do you know like why
differentiate this white is more
pronounced in the brain cells yeah yeah
i think that that has become pretty
clear with a lot of work that's been
done in this area so basically this
virus appears to have some specific
tropism so it has tropism for mental
trophoblast which is one of the reasons
why it goes and multiplies there it has
tourism for
cortical neural progenitors in the brain
and the cortex and so basically when it
goes into the brain it kills the
progenitor cells so when it does not and
Anglia and radial glia because when it
does bad you just basically don't get
developmental cortex it doesn't affect
many of the other cells it seems to
affect and it doesn't affect
differentiate itself it's just affect
the neural progenitors and the same
thing in the testis it appears to affect
spermatogonial stem cells not mature
sperm but it affects the stem cells so
it's killing them and and so it seems to
go to these specific places it doesn't
seem to do anything in the liver or in
the spleen or even an intestine you know
so clearly it's got like it goes at
things that are very important to human
reproduction and and human existence
stuff it's that's why I always carried
sperm stem cells central cells and brain
cells you know yeah that's bit like do
you know like why specifically like you
mentioned about the proposed ohms or
whatever but is there any way that it
happens only to these organs yes this is
a question that's been kind of confusing
so the clear hypothesis would be that
there must be receptors on these cells
that the virus binds to and it's true
that these babies cells have receptors
they belong to a tyrosine kinase
receptor family they call tam receptors
but how they're functioning in these
cells is still little confusing because
because people have made mice where they
knocked out these receptors and it
didn't make any difference to the
infection the infection was just as bad
as normal but in some human cells may
opt the receptor and they see some
reduced infection so the literature is a
little bit
news right now these receptors important
or not are they maybe not sufficient
maybe there are other receptors starting
all that stuff is ongoing my god and now
going back to this is the last question
I don't hold your comment like regarding
the UTA you mentioned that in like that
is it is a wire of these wireless this
didn't happen in all other organs like
lime like we have viral infections like
for example cold and all those things so
some people keep on getting those poor
like quite frequently but not others you
know do you think that similar mechanism
exists inside at all yeah that's a great
question um yeah yes or no I guess I
guess then you may have some sometimes
it's a question of the virus or the
bacteria itself persisting long-term and
reservoirs and sometimes it's a question
of what kind of immune response is put
in place and if you have an active
continued chronic immune response then
it doesn't need another that doesn't
need the physical micro the any new
microbe had to get exposed to can
contribute the same response so
typically but a lot of people don't this
is this is what comes down to with with
studying things more holistically is
that you think about all these things
whereas many microbiologists looking
from the microbial perspective and see
what happens in the microbe a lot of
immunologists look at what happens in
the immune cells a lot of physiology
host to should people look at host
damage and after infection but but
nobody's necessarily a lot of people
going to say look at all three things at
the same time so it's possible that
other infections also have those of ours
I mean so today we know like toxoplasma
I can do this in the brain
hysteria could potentially I mean
there's definitely a malarial parasite
makes as a forcible liver chlamydia can
make reservoirs in the vagina and cause
infections so certainly it's known for
some of them but whether all the other
infections also have reservoirs I think
has not done I think we are almost out
of time so I again thank you so much for
joining us I really appreciate it so
good luck with your research and they
look forward to more of these hangouts
with you okay Luce to thank you very
much for meeting thank you so much